تميز دائما الذي كان عنوانا دائما في قناه
العربيه اليوم نحصل ثمار هذا الجهد
المبذول من فريقنا المميز بالفعل
المشاهدينا ثمان 38 او 88 جائزه حصدتها
العربيه بينها خمس جوائز ذهبيه ضمن جوائز
تالي التي تعنى بتكريم التميز في مجال
التلفزيون والفيديو ابرز الفئات التي فازت
بها العربيه كانت البرامج الثقافيه
والتاريخيه وكذلك التصميم والابداع وايضا
الوثائقيه بالاضافه الى السوشيال ميديا
واستخدام تقنيات الواقع المعزز تاتي طبعا
الجائزه التي تنظم سنويا في امريكا في
نسختها الرابعه والاربعين شاركت فيها مئات
القنوات والمؤسسات الاعلاميه مثل
[موسيقى]
الف مبروك طبعا بقناه العربيه وللعاملين
فيها مبروك لالكم
هذه المجهودات التي على مدى الطويل دائما
ما تتطور العربيه وتستخدم التقنيات
الحديثه اضافه الى هذه البرامج التي
تجعلنا متميزين لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه وال
وثائق لازر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات